all right now we're ready for part two
of the Millie Awards we've got a bunch
of categories like breakout company or
product of the year the who is the
craziest SL most delusional person we
met this year uh as well as things like
our favorite content books podcasts that
we consumed what is the best of the best
and U one of my favorites is unsexy
business of the year so what's a
business that on the surface looks maybe
boring or it flies under the radar but
actually secretly crushes it we each
share our own so enjoy part two of the
Millie Awards
[Music]
all right next category that we have is
the craziest most delusional person that
you met this year so somebody who is
kind of out there they broke your frame
a little bit
and it could be good delusional crazy it
could be bad delusional crazy there's
this is just saying this person thinks
way differently than you and uh and
there there are bit like they're living
in their own world and so um this was a
tough one for me I was a tough category
Sam who did you have so the easy one was
Elon Musk do you guys we already forgot
about how Elon and Zuck almost got in a
fight that was hilarious I think elon's
insane but I didn't want to pick him
because that's too easy so I chose this
guy named Val who I've met via Hampton
you probably have seen him on Twitter
his name's uh so like basically Val was
under the radar for years and years I
mean he's probably 45 years old so he
just started using Twitter but he built
a bunch of businesses he was a Soviet
Union uh immigrant came here to America
age 19 built a business that made $10
million in profit in year one I started
hanging out with him and now he's got
this
massive set of businesses that probably
do like $150 or $200 million a year in
Revenue that he owns he's never raised
money for any of them I invested in
right when I met him I invested into one
of his real estate deals and he was new
to it and I got a great return and so I
did another one with him and I started
talking to him and he's like yeah we own
this many tens of millions of dollars of
Brooklyn real estate and I was like Val
what the hell how'd you figure out how
to do this he goes well I just did the
math and I did this and I did this and
he was so logical and yet so calm about
it and he was comfortable with the wrist
so I got to give love to Val and here's
a fun fact about him I started talking
to him even more he wakes up at 4:00 am
and he starts working at 3M and
basically works until 4: am and that's
his life and I'm like there's so many
reasons why that's bad and he was calmly
just saying like yeah but it works for
me and he's got five kids I love people
that got tons of kids so this guy's the
best he seems like a good dad a good
husband but he does crazy business stuff
just absolutely crazy but he's so calm
about it so he's one of the craziest
people that I've ever met Andrew you
wantan to go next sure so I actually
struggled um I think I said Brian
Johnson he was the person that comes to
mind uh he really really nice
interesting guy but definitely crazy all
the health stuff he's doing Elon Musk is
another obvious answer but I actually
couldn't think of somebody that was
crazy and so I actually inverted it I
said who is the sest calest most most
boring person and Chris and I got to
meet Michael Dell this year and Michael
Dell is worth $65 billion that's insane
and we sat down with him I'm I'm going
like okay I'm gonna crack this guy open
right like you read his book it's all
very tame his public Persona is very
like you know serious and calm and nice
and all that kind of stuff his his book
is literally called play nice but win
and so me and Chris we go into this
office you
know
sorry go ahead so so we go into this
this huge gray like Office Park we're in
this boardroom and he sits down with us
and Chris and I just walked away we were
like oh my God he's like the C I Can't
Believe It's Not Butter of billionaires
like he's just like steady yeed super
nice and we're asking him we're like
dude what do you do with your money like
you know have you gone like have you you
know do you own 20 houses do you own you
know a bunch of planes do you do
anything crazy and he's like nope I just
love you know operating my business and
uh growing it over time I own two nice I
think he owns two nice or three nice
houses obviously they're very very nice
houses one plane and that was it we
couldn't get anything out of them and he
told us this anecdote this is how much
of a baller he is he goes yeah so uh
about 20 years ago I took 200 million
and I started a family office and in the
family office I wanted to make like a
10% return and so I hired these really
smart guys and they started doing
private credit and I don't know if you
guys know that is but usually it's um
lending to people that the bank will
lend to so it's higher risk uh lending
and one of the people he lent to was a I
think a billionaire who owned a hockey
team I think in Dallas or something when
when you were saying that I just I was
thinking of like your cousin Dom down
the street who's like G to go buy like a
rookie LeBron card and flip it I
guess totally so so he goes he goes yeah
and then one day I just got a call and
uh they said well you own the Dallas
Stars now I think it was the Dallas
Stars but some professional sports team
and he had just literally just owned it
because he had lent the guy money and
the guy defaulted like that's how much
of a baller Michael Dell is dude he
totally sfed your ass he Elizabeth homes
you I bet you Michael Dell is just
basement dude the basement's got
something crazy in it this guy is lying
to you Michael Dell is in order to get
there Andrew you know more than me but
in order to get there you have to be the
sharkiest of all
sharks I don't I don't agree with that
what there is no I think you have to be
you have to be very aggressive but I do
think you can you can be a you have if
you have to be a wacko right you have to
go you have to be a maniac you have to
go extreme but I think you could be
nice I can't find this client info have
you heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
dude have you ever used a Dell computer
a Dell computer is the technology
equivalent of what you just described
it's like the uh the most Can't Believe
It's Not Butter of computers that that
by the way I don't even know what that
analogy means but I it just made sense
when he when he said it it's kind of an
insult I think right no it's like he's
just like he's straightforward you know
it's it's like saying someone is a you
know they're the missionary position of
of lending and it's like exactly did you
just diss me it's like no missionary is
great everybody loves it right and it's
like yeah but you don't want to be
called
missionary he's the dad jeans of
billionaires uh Sean what's your's like
nicest guy ever yeah right dude no I
swear to God right when you walked out
the room he was probably here's how I
know here's how I know you can always
tell whether someone's like a psycho or
scary based on how their employees talk
about them right their employees love
him they gosh about him they're he's so
nice he was so respectful to everyone
someone came in and brought water to him
he looked him in the eye and said their
name and said thank you like he is a
nice
guy the profound story you just told
that was amazing I thought that was
going to be something crazy what your
shot all right um so this was kind of
tough but then I realized I had an
answer so I did a call the other day
with a guy Ben was like you got to meet
this guy I met him at a brunch and Ben's
thing is he always says this guy's got
the juice I was like he got the juice he
goes this guy's overflowing with the
juice I was like all right I got to meet
this guy so get on a call you don't seem
like a brunch guy what were you doing I
wasn't at the brunch Ben was at the
brunch
so you know like in when people used to
fight back in the day and they'd be like
I nominate my second to fight for me
that's Ben Ben does all the fighting he
gets out in the real order and meets
people so anyways he uh he's like you
gotta be this guy we get on a call and
the guy's like he starts talking and
immediately I love him why because I
love the Middle Eastern accent anyone
who's like Persian Iranian my friend
they like oh my God I love like they
could tell me any story they could tell
me that same Michael Dell story and I
would have felt like it's an HBO
documentary like it's so good to me so
anyways he he's got the accent point one
point two he goes love your podcast look
look I have a podcast too he holds up
these headphones he goes me and my wife
we get high and then we record it and I
was like okay all right and then he's
like that's just how we started we
hadn't even said anything yet he's like
um I'm like so what do you work on and
he's like I uh he's like American food
is [__]
and I'm like I think I agree but okay
where you coming from with this and he's
like I um he's like I'm a super smart
guy sold my last company decided I he's
like I went back to Turkey where I'm
from and I ate a banana and I was like
this is what food is supposed to taste
like so he's like I realize I can use AI
to grow better crops like I can
literally grow better food uh if I take
everything in machine learning he's like
I trained a data set on all like
scientific papers I scraped all the
scientific papers from like the journals
and I trained a g version of GPT only on
that and I tried to figure out what
could I do to get more minerals in the
soil so that American food which is like
it's the same food it's a banana but it
tastes bad and it doesn't it doesn't
taste like as rich as it does in other
places and it's like deficient in all
these minerals and so he's like I'm
gonna um grow more mineral rich food
he's like I have the best he's like you
like dried berries and I was like I kind
of love dried berries to be honest with
you and he's like I'm going to send you
dried berries right now he's like these
are the best berries had and he's like
one serving of this is 60% of your daily
vitamin C intake and I have like we buy
Whole Foods whatever you go look at that
it'll be like 5% like it's like nothing
and he's like no no this is 60% and he's
like uh we grow it without soil and I'm
like I don't even understand what that
means but okay he sends me these berries
my kids are obsessed with them they
taste so goddamn good and I'm like you
know getting all these minerals so I'm
like this guy actually might not be full
of [__] um then he's like I'm like okay
what's uh is that like your main thing
he's like yeah it's that he's like but I
also love to give back he's like you
know I immigrated here it really changed
my life he's like so I'm going to bring
10,000 Turkish Engineers to America
engineers and lawyers and I was like
what he's like yeah my business plan is
I'm G to bring 10,000 engineers and
10,000 lawyers to America from turkey
and for those people in Turkey it's
going to change their life and for
America you're G to get high you know
super smart Talent that's going to come
here and work um and I was like how why
is that your goal and how do you even do
that and he's like basically figured out
an entire like by the book way to get
people visas systematically and
programmatically um and he's like and he
created a model where he's like
basically he he brings you over and you
have a little income share so you're
going to start making 100K plus a year
um as a lawyer or or an engineer he
takes the income share of that he
invests it and bringing the next
engineer over he's like I basically have
to fund 10 of these guys if I fund 10 I
can get to 10,000 and I was like this
guy is thinking on a totally different
wavelength the way he worked out this
this plan I thought was great his
overall energy was great and he was not
just working differently than most
people are thinking differently he just
worked on different things than anybody
I know like I don't know anyone that's
trying to grow like mineral Rich berries
and bring 10,000 people immigrants into
the country like that's what this guy's
game plan was by the way I gotta share
you share with you guys a funny
conversation I had I shared it with Sean
and I'll and I'll read it here but
basically uh I didn't want to bring this
guy up because I've talked about him so
much and I get made fun of but I
invested in this guy this guy's company
named Brett Adcock he's like my my I
have a man crush on him and he's got
this robot company and he sent me a
picture of like the robots and how
they're like moving and it's amazing and
uh I was like wow that's amazing you've
done all this stuff in 18 months and uh
you've not raised a lot of money is this
like a business that you can like not
raise a lot of money for and you can uh
own a lot of it and his response is a
perfect example of why crazy people
exist and how I'm just absolutely not
one of them he says well this is for
btim well it's going to cost a little
under a trillion dollars to ship 10
billion robots so I don't think it'll
work without raising
uh and I was like yeah [__] me right
like what do I know uh I'm gonna go
tweet I'll be BRB basically to this
guy's building AI robots and you you
asked him the equivalent of like hey
have you thought about just doing a
newsletter about it
instead you're like do you think you
could just bootstrap this and not raise
any money he's like I need a trillion
dollars I felt like such a little [__]
when he said that I was like yeah yeah
you're you're
right um all right what about best and
worst Investments for the year yeah this
is my favorite category uh Andrew you've
had the best stories in this I think you
have the most you're the probably the
most prolific investor that comes on
this pod so can you give us yours give
us your best and
worst so um yeah my best was I I was in
New Zealand I've been working on getting
my New Zealand citizenship for the last
two years years or so and so I had this
yeah yeah they have this um there's this
as part of the program there's this
mandatory conference that I had to go to
and I was absolutely dreading it I'd
been traveling a whole bunch but I I you
know I got go I had to go and I was
thinking about it and going okay well
who do I know in Auckland New Zealand
and I realized I'd met this guy Matt
Buchanan about 10 years ago at South by
Southwest he ran an uh design agency at
the time and he had started this website
called letterbox do you guys know what
letter box is yeah it's like a movie
thing what is it so social network for
film Buffs and it started out really
really small it was just like you know
hundreds of people at first just
discussing films um and then over time
and especially over covid it grown like
crazy and so Matt and I met up for
coffee and uh I just asked him about you
know how everything was going I I wasn't
at all thinking about investing or
buying it and he started telling me that
they had 10 million registered users
that had grown like crazy and at the end
of the coffee I literally just blurred
it out do you want to sell and he was
like well I hadn't really even thought
about that uh and I was like throw me
the craziest number you can think of and
so he threw the number out and I said
okay and I sent him an offer within 48
hours and we just bought that business
we didn't buy all of it we bought I
think 60% of it uh about three months
ago did you buy it for the number he
said uh yeah the valuation I think I
think it worked out to about $60 million
valuation something like that and there
was three guys yeah no it was about I
think there's about 10 10 or so
employees all in New Zealand so totally
bootstrapped uh new zealand-based um
designer and developer started it like
incredible business they're going to
keep running it but um it's it's an
example of you know we bought a business
called dribble about eight years ago uh
which is a social network and social
networks are just incredible businesses
I call them like airports you know if
you own the airport you can put a you
can you've got this group of people
that's going to congregate there uh on a
consistent schedule and you can sell
them you know all sorts of stuff you can
sell them a book you can sell them a hot
dog you can sell them a massage and as
long as you don't mess with them uh and
you keep the community happy um you know
you can do some incredible stuff so I'm
uh I'm super excited about that dude
this is your in for uh for Zuck you can
go back to Zuck hey Mark uh I told you
it was a good idea social Network owner
sh you got one I got two but who's
counting uh happy to meet I finally got
my end yeah you guys can start your own
little Facebook group of social media
own yeah social media owners and your
best one last year was girl boss your
worst one last year was venture capital
in general what's your worst one this
year so my worst one this year it was an
investment I made about five years ago
and it's a great example of shiny object
syndrome uh lack of focus and what I
call money bonfire so I bought a podcast
player called Castro about five years
ago and at the time I was really hopped
up about um podcasts and subscription
podcasting and uh you was around the
time I started coming on MFM actually
and I bought the business because I was
excited about the space not because I
had a plan and so the business basically
um just languished the founders left um
I couldn't find anyone uh you know we
couldn't find the right person to run it
and just every month I you know I I
think I bought it for a million bucks
and it just lost 10 to 20K a month and
it was a small enough number that
blended into all my other stuff I just
didn't really notice it it wasn't like
an urgent thing and so this tiny little
Ember turned into a money bonfire and so
I think I lost $2 million or something
over the last five years on this
business um and now I'm in the process
of selling it but anyone want it good if
you too would like a money Bond maybe
maybe someone who wants to get into
podcasting um but anyway it is it is one
of those things where uh I've done this
so many times where I start something
and it's a runaway train and I just
don't get the right people in and it
just slowly Burns money dude unless
you're like a huberman or or you know
host like us I think podcasting could be
good I think podcasting as like Venture
Capital companies mostly is [__] it's a
very hard business I think to build
tools for we get pitched all the time on
like people who are trying to make
podcasts more discoverable or this or
that it's a hard business that's a hard
industry yeah yeah 100% uh Sam what you
got best and worst investment of the
Year all right uh I don't remember what
I what did I say last year for best do
you know did it say so um tell me that
in a second but all right my best
investment man one weekend I was talking
to my wife I was like Hey we're gonna
have kids one day uh do you want to keep
working or what do you want to do and
she was kind of telling me and I was
like well I'll tell you what to make
your decision a little bit easier I've
got this idea for a little copywriting
thing I'm just going to put it together
because it's fun and it's how I taught
my team how to write and it's how I
learned how to write I'm just going to
do this for fun and if it works maybe
one day you'll want to quit your job and
run this turns out she doesn't want to
but I made it anyway yeah so it didn't
work now I run this yeah so I made this
thing called copy that.com it I just did
it for fun I did it over the weekend and
that one little thing that I made it
pays for my living expenses um I I I
don't really do much for it I don't do
anything for it and it pays for my
living expenses and and for some reason
like some of my other things like this
podcast or um Hampton like when things
get a little bit bigger you can't really
deviate or move quickly and I just use
this and and also I have Partners so
I've got like Sean's my partner in this
podcast and then with Hampton I have a
business partner and I've got customers
and things like that I can't really do
what I want all the time just like on a
whim and so I used this as like a little
bit of of a playground to do whatever
the hell I want and it's been fun and so
really enjoyed it my worst investment so
so far Sean I've invested about a
million dollars into companies via Angel
Investing I have seen not $1 doll back
since I started doing it in
2016 I've got a lot of markups that that
$1 million is maybe worth $5 million on
paper but paper don't pay my mortgage at
least not this type of paper and uh I
it's pissed me off because I knew what
it was going into it
and I just don't like having to have the
patience or not having any involvement
and so that's probably been my worst so
far I don't think it's going to be worse
in terms of Roi but I think it's worse
in terms of I just don't enjoy it you
know what's interesting is I've Got a
Friend um he's an angel investor and he
sold his company like you and he said
I've always wanted to be an angel
investor and so he invested in um five
companies and two of them paid him back
10x within two years and so he learned
the wrong lesson lesson right because
that's not most people's experience then
he doubled down on Angel Investing For 5
years didn't see a single return for 10
years and so I think it's like anything
if you try something the first time and
it it gives you a win you love it like I
guarantee you if you have already gotten
$2 million back awesome you'd be like I
love Angel Investing it's the best right
but what you've really done is you've
gone into the casino and gambled maybe
with like a slight Edge but you're
really gambling and I I feel the exact
same way I have barely seen any money
back have you seen any money back Andrew
yeah I have but it took 12 years for the
first one well was it
significant uh yeah so I put in 75 grand
into a business um and I got 800 Grand
back and then I put uh 250,000 into one
and I got three million back but I also
over the next period invested like 20 or
$30 million in the Venture so so it
canceled out all the other gains and it
it all comes down to like when you're
investing the you know the uh the year
you're investing right if you invest in
2020 and 2021 like it's just
everything's out the window yeah well
we'll see Sean have you seen any money
that's the year I started my rolling
fund um here which is ironic actually
the first the first batch of Investments
we did were uh so far are the highest
performers the first like six
Investments we did were the were the
best batch um which is kind of
interesting well you've picked a handful
of winners I know a few that you've
picked and you've got a couple really
really you don't get the you don't get
liquidity until if it's a winner it's
going to run for 10 years right so it's
not a good thing to do if you need cash
you know today which is like you yeah
I've got I've got winners I mean it's
gon to be good it's just boring just
lame well okay my best and worst
investment all right so my best I had a
couple more interesting examples but I'm
just going to say the one that's
actually the best so the truthful answer
is clearly hands down Shephard um so I
had this idea mostly inspired by you
Andrew which was wow this guy does
really well and he doesn't have to start
and invent the next big thing so you
know you buy businesses that already are
working and then maybe already have a
Tailwind so they're going to just keep
working at a greater rate in the future
like when you got into like the say the
the Shopify ecosystem with with wec
Commerce I was like oh that makes sense
to me buy something that's already
working that has a tailwind and
hopefully you can accelerate it or make
it work better but
even if you don't you can still make
good money if you buy at the right price
and we got like a basically like it's a
crazy result so far out of the shepher
deal so had this idea which was let me
find a product that I use that I like
that I kind of believe in of a business
that's already working Shephard fit the
bill Buy in We Buy in this case a
minority stake not a majority stake so
that uh Marshall would keep operating
the thing um and keep growing it the
Tailwinds were were behind us basically
first it was covid so people went remote
that was one big Tailwind second
Tailwind was when the economy started to
slow down over the last year everybody
started to realize they need to be
profitable well one way to be profitable
is hire talent for five times less than
your currently hiring talent in the
United States and so higher offshore
Talent became like a very obvious thing
for business owners to do if they wanted
profits and so Shepard just takes off
and and the third piece which was can we
accelerate it and we had done a couple
of experiments of like look we have this
audience right between Twitter is almost
half a million people the podcast is way
bigger than that newsletter we have a
diff you we have not just a big numbers
but like big trust that has been built
up so if we pick a product that we
actually believe in I think this will
work we the last I don't know we've only
owned the owned our stake of the
business for like six to nine months or
something like that the business has
tripled and it was already big to begin
with and so this is just like an
incredible result what how much of that
is because of you well we could see it
because when people people sign up they
either sign up through our link or they
sign up and they say where they found it
from and so that's a minimum like
there's some people who they have heard
about it on the podcast but don't click
the link or don't whatever and
uh Nick does a great job too so I don't
want to like you know take away from
that but like in the last six months we
drove like 50% more of the leads to the
business it's like a a pretty insane uh
you know value driver and so now I'm
like oh I have an unfair Advantage if I
I don't need to do 10 of these if I just
find a couple of businesses that are
already Standalone good businesses that
I believe
and I do the same thing if I can add
millions of dollars of ARR to this
business I basically can't lose that
that is a that is a completely unfair
Advantage uh to have and now all I have
to do is Choose Wisely and uh so that's
what I've been doing we only did one
deal this year and um it we saw you know
maybe 60 or so but I think we picked the
right one because that investment has
has paid off that business has added
probably that one deal he did like I
thought I was getting it at a good price
but it has added at least 30 5 million
of value just to that business um just
based on the growth and so uh that's
like a crazy deal for him too so you
know good good on Marshall for for
cutting that it's interesting because
like I think um I assume that he did it
as a secondary or something like that he
wanted D RIS take money off the table
Yeah but effectively it's like a primary
still because you've injected call it 10
or20 million of free marketing as part
of the partnership right exact it's
super smart and it goes back to that
idea I think I've talked about it on the
Pod but one plus one equals 100 you can
take a mediocre business and I think
Shephard's a great business so better if
it's a great business well that's not
how math Works no it's not right but but
you can take you can take you can take
something you can take a product and you
combine it with an influencer and you
can get an incredible outcome because
you basically have a free $50 million a
year marketing budget as a result well
people had talked about this but like
you know when I think of influencer I
think of like Kim Kardashian or like you
know uh Mr Beast it's like yeah
obviously you know if they promote a
product it's going to go really well
it turns out that there's a thing like
B2B influencer right there's like a
person who is respected amongst business
people who is essentially like you know
I'm not saying my ass is big but like
we're kind of the Kim Kardashian of
business influencers right like there
you can you you could promote to a
community that that that understands
what you're doing and if you again if
you pick a good product with a good
business it will actually take off if
you have a shitty product or a shitty
business they'll try it and then it'll
leak out like right away and so it
doesn't really work literally this is
what HubSpot did HubSpot looked at the
hustle and they said well right now
they're making call it $20 million I
don't know what the number is $20
million of AD Revenue but how much are
those advertisers making off that $20
million of AD spend maybe it's 30
million or 40 million or 50 million and
so they can pay up to buy this business
and then they can just direct the
traffic to themselves and make all that
money and I've seen the numbers I think
it's a good I think it works for them
and let me tell you a crazy thing about
this she deal I haven't shared before so
the way we structured this deal was
beautifully done so I was like look here
the business is good the business was
already spitting off millions of dollars
of profit so it's like cool guys I can
bring you guys Capital but you kind of
already have like a cash cow that's
spitting off millions of dollars of
profit so like what I don't really want
to well that's not really the value ad
clearly the value ad is going to be that
I can help grow this actual grow the
customer base right because because of
the audience and so essentially I put a
very small amount of money down and then
the company lent me the money to buy my
stake in the company that's insane and I
was like what and I was like did they
type this wrong they're going to give me
the money to buy the the business give
me the money to buy the business like
all right deals where where do I sign
this is easy and it was a great deal for
me but again like I said the valuation
of the company has grown over $30
million just in that period of time and
so like less than a year so so like I
thought dude I'm getting an absolute
steal here turns out they got actually
even a bigger steal than I got you know
was like win-win and so that's deal
structure because that's another thing
I've learned when you when it comes to
buying companies like in Venture there's
no structure Venture is you put in money
on a safe note or a priced round it's
not even negotiating on really the terms
unless you're the lead investor and
you're doing something really funky but
it's not standard at all when it comes
to buying companies structure is can
make the difference between a good deal
and incred rible deal or a terrible deal
and uh structure really really matters I
learned a ton about structure this year
negotiating a bunch of these deals so
Shephard kicked ass for you you did
great let's move to the biggest L that
you took this year what was that one
last year at the end of the year this
time last year I was like Hey tax
optimization why don't I sell a bunch of
my crypto for tax purposes because with
crypto you can watch trade you could
basically sell and buy back the next day
you could book the loss cuz crypto was
down last year let's say um so you could
book a loss on any crypto that you had
bought um higher than that and so crypto
was crashing crypto went down to like I
don't know six Bitcoin went down to like
16k and I had bought a bunch of Bitcoin
at uh when we were doing the milk Road
probably closer to to 30k so I could
book a you know big loss and then I was
like great I'm just gonna buy it right
back I believe in crypto right but there
is a funny psychological thing where you
know catching a falling knife it's like
I could buy back in but like should I
buy back in now is it go lower uh you
know should I just kind of wait this out
and see how it goes maybe I'll just do
this other thing that that that thing's
hot right now crypto's cold right now so
let me just wait I'm gonna do it but
I'll do it you know at the end of the
month and I said I'll do it at the end
of the month for 10 months straight just
enough time for Bitcoin to RI back up
another 35 40% and I bought back in and
you know
it's my tax savings cost me a lot of
money so that was a big L that I took
falling into a bunch of obvious
psychological traps that I could have
pointed out for anybody else that I fell
into now luckily for me I didn't sell
all of it because I bought Bunch lower
than that so it wasn't like that part
wouldn't have been a Tex loss but uh
still dumb that's that's the second time
you've done that that I know of by my
course sell low buy high right like
that's basically what I executed to
Perfection this year um I have one more
that was like a big Miss wait what is it
so we talked about Angel Investing and
Angel Investing we're talking about like
getting returns every the game of angel
investing is you you're going to invest
in 30 maybe 50 companies and it's going
to be one or two that are like the
runaway winners that's really what
you're playing the game for it's like
you not trying to have a high hit rate
you're trying to have a huge slugging
percentage so a few just absolute grand
slams and um I missed
two Two's A Lot two's the number you
need to win and I missed two the first
is a the realization here was it's not
it's not about bad Investments you make
it's the ones you miss it's about the
incredible ADV Investments you miss and
that's in Venture that's what that
that's how it goes so I got introduced
to a company called whatnot that I don't
know if you guys have heard about this
business we talked about it on the Pod
you were early talking about it it's
like eBay I talked about it I believed
in it I was like dude I was at twitch
it's basically live video streaming and
it started with uh baseball cards and
then sports cards so basically people
would open up a pack live but you would
buy the pack so it's like live they're
sitting there they got all these packs
on the table you would buy one he would
open it up and he would be like you got
a Luca donic rookie card wow this is
amazing and the chat's going wild and
you could just keep buying packs and so
it was like this like kind of live video
sort of like
Casino I like all those words live video
and casino so I was like all right I
want to invest and the guy's like I
don't know man we're we're like pretty
over subscribed I'm like but it's me
it's a pal Sean we just met uh please
and he was like all right let me think
about it and I didn't he was like I
don't think so I don't think we have
space so let me let me go talk to some
people see if I can make space and I
made a big mistake I waited and I didn't
chase and uh whatnot is now valued I
think at10 billion so that would have
been by far the best investment in all
of my Angel Investing I was there early
on and I believed in it and I wanted to
invest and I just did not fight hard
enough to find a way to get into that
company and um so you know it's in Angel
Investing it's not about oh I made this
one bad investment and I lost one X it's
that I missed out on you know a 200x or
a 500x return on that one deal right
like that my 150k check that I wanted to
get into that would have been like a $30
million position at this point so one
one question was it when was it valued
at 10
billion um I think it is it might have
been at the kind of peak time July 2022
they raised at 3.7 yeah so okay so maybe
it's at four billion now instead of
instead of uh 10 um so anyways uh you
know basically that would have been a
multi-billion dollar uh you know it's a
multi-billion dollar company now which
is all you're trying to do in investing
same thing happened with uh a company
called Shuffle so my former intern who
came on the Pod I did an episode where I
was like my my old intern became a
millionaire um when we were hanging out
doing the Pod I was like so what are you
doing now and he's like oh I'm doing
this again this crypto Casino overseas
and I was like I like all those words
when it comes to making money that's I I
wouldn't want to take the risk myself of
running that company but if you're going
to run that company I think it's a it's
a great investment because these things
you know we've talked about stake.com
that is just this absolute Juggernaut
stake is you know issuing like billion
dollar dividends a year they have so
much cash flow and these guys were
building like a
competitor and I wanted to invest and
then our like lawyer in back office was
like yeah but they're based out of this
country so they're not going to provide
the k1s in time uh blah BL blah and I
was in a fund and I was like I can't put
my fund money into this because again
it's like this overseas crypto Casino
thing and the fund cost me this thing is
going to be a total winner uh it looks
like their their volume is growing like
crazy I think they have like I don't
know I'll look up the latest numbers I
mean it's just painful every time he
tells me the latest numbers where it's
like every day is their biggest day and
uh you know they're they're doing
millions and millions of dollars of
daily betting volume and they're
profitable and I'm like [__] you know
you know what's interesting is like you
might feel like you've missed the boat
on that but one of the things I've
learned is like think about amazon.com
right amazon.com launched in what
1994 and you you you know you basically
had until
2012 to buy the stock right now
obviously it's publicly traded stock
easier to get into but I bet you could
go to him and say hey remember your old
pal Sean can I put a 100 Grand in or
whatever it is and just suck it up right
don't get caught up in the fact that you
could have invested at some low
valuation that sounds like it'll be a
winner long term right yeah and I mean
who knows that's a super high variance
bet like they get shut down tomorrow if
like wherever they're based in some
little island somewhere gets like you
know seized you know uh who knows what's
going to happen with that but that's a
roller coaster I wanted to be on if
you're going to do Angel Investing you
need High variance bets that can become
absolutely massive or go to zero you
don't want things that are low risk low
reward that's not how Angel Investing
works anyways so those are my two worst
Investments they're Miss missed out not
lost money what's yours
Andrew so um I'm a designer like I like
um you know I like things to look nice
and I think every designer has this
dream of building their dreamhouse and
so uh about seven years ago I bought a
piece of property and I started building
a amazing house and I hired amazing
Architects and interior designers and
I'll just say now if you think you want
to build a house try it it really sucks
uh you know everyone has this fantasy
but what it really is you know you think
it's going to be about approving like
beautiful exteriors what it really comes
down to is you are choosing where the
electrical outlets go you are proving
what you know what color tone all the
lights are and so you make 10,000
decisions and eventually you get
decision fatigue and you start making
bad decisions or if you delegate you
delegate someone else and someone else
is just you know they delegation is
great in a company but when you live in
this space the things bother you and so
what I found was I because I was
building my forever home I would approve
they'd be like okay do you want um this
marble or there's this really really
really nice marble that you can get
where it's got you know nicer designs or
whatever and I'd always choose the more
expensive option because I was thinking
this is my dream home I only get to
build it once and so I'm massively
overbuilt I massively overspent I ended
up not being happy with the actual house
once I was done wasn't the house like
8,000 square feet was huge I had
everything I could have wanted a gym I
had a movie theater all all sorts of
stuff and I ended up not even liking the
house when I moved in because i' just
walk around the house going godamn it I
remember making that decision you know
why did I make that beam that height why
did I put that light there and uh anyway
so I ended up getting divorced a year
and a half ago and neither me or my
ex-wife wanted the house and so I had to
sell it and I took a 30% loss on this
house that I'd spent you know five years
building and spent tons of money on so
that was my uh that was my big loss and
my big lesson is I remember my dad said
you always want to be the second owner
of a hotel right you want someone else
to go crazy and build it out and then go
bankrupt and then you want to come in
and own that I think the same thing is
true with houses just go buy a nice
house that someone else built that's a
great line you had an even bigger one
though written down here yeah the other
the other thing that happened to me this
year so this this is this has happened
to everybody but no one feels it so this
year uh my net worth got cut in half on
paper right so I went from my let's just
say what's publicly available so my tiny
stock was worth like 750 $800 billion do
and today it's worth about half of that
and it's really fascinating like when
you're when you own a private business
or you own a real estate State portfolio
you don't have a ticker right if you own
a million-dollar house and all the
houses in your neighborhood go down by
20% you don't see that you're not
reminded of that and one of the crazy
things about having a stock a stock
ticker is every day you can see your net
worth go up and down in radical ways uh
and so yeah that kind of was pretty a
pretty insane experience to see that
happening over the course of six months
I would never text you this but I
remember like seeing the stock and every
once while be like not I just want to be
like what is that feel like you know
what I mean like because there's been
days when it's gone way up and there's
been days it's gone way down and I've
always curious that I'm like he knows
what's going on I wna I'm gonna stay out
of his hair on this one it's really
weird I mean Warren Buffett has this
great anecdote where or or metaphor
where he says owning a business is like
owning a farm let's say that your farm
makes a million dollars a year of profit
and some some yokul comes to your fence
and he starts yelling I'll buy your farm
for 100 grand if you know your farm is
worth millions of dollars you just
ignore the Y and so there's all sorts of
different people shouting different
offers on your farm at all times and so
that's kind of the approach I try and
take is I just go like um you know I
know my business I know what it's worth
but yeah it's pretty weird seeing big
swings like
that my worst thing this year was my
biggest L was partially inspired by
Andrew Andrew you make a huge mistake
when you're talking to me the mistake is
you say oh it's just easy you just hire
a CEO and then
and you miss out on two things one It
Ain't Easy there's it's always harder
than you think there's always more
challenges than you think the other
thing is managing them you know how how
should they manage you how should you
manage them the thing with my company
Hampton my CEO Jordan he's awesome but
it's heavily based on my reputation and
I'm heavily involved in the product and
so when I want to be involved in the
product I've made mistakes where I'll
just go directly to certain staff versus
like understanding the chain of command
and so just like understanding like how
to uh like work with the CEO effectively
has been a little bit of a challenge
with me i' I it's going great and things
are going good and I've made a lot of
really good decisions and he's wonderful
but just learning how to like understand
that relationship has been a challenge
and I've gotten in trouble a few times
partially I I take blame for a lot of
the the instances but I wish we would
have talked more about how to manage
them tactically we've talked a lot about
how to hire and fire and things like
that but not how to like work with
someone on a daily or weekly or monthly
basis yeah and I lots of learning there
because I think it's very tempting to
see a mistake and jump in but it's it's
similar to delegation right when you
first start delegating to an employee
you want to correct the errors as you
see them but at the end of the day the
hardest part about having a CEO is that
they can ruin the business if they're
not careful and you ultimately have to
let them make their own mistakes and
learn from them I think I've shared on
the Pod like we've had a couple
instances where a CEO wants to spend one
two3 million on R&D and we don't believe
it's going to work out but we let them
because we go if we don't they're going
to resent us they're going to say Andrew
and Chris were holding us back we
couldn't make our bonuses because we
couldn't execute on the strategy and so
we always say um we want non-fatal
errors not fatal errors we'll intervene
when they're fatal right so I think for
you like intervening when it's something
that's going to ruin your reputation you
should jump on that or ruin the business
or imperil it but otherwise the hard
part is you just kind of have to watch
them make mistakes and realize that over
the long term they'll make more um make
more good decisions than
bad yeah and it's just an emotional
these are emotional issues but um that's
mine Sean what do you want to do now
which one let's go to one of my
favorites so unsexy business so what is
a unsexy kind of under the radar maybe
simple business uh that stood out to you
that you really liked let me go first on
this one I've got one that's interesting
so there's a this guy I went to high
school with named Chris Chris Hoffman he
just started posting content on Twitter
like three months ago so basically he
posted a story but I'd known what his
father did so his father owned a heating
and cooling company called Hoffman Bros
Heating and Cooling out of St Louis
where I'm from he posted he goes in 2016
we took over my father's company um I
bought it from him and it was doing 13
million in revenue and he goes through
2016 all the way up to 2013 where he
explained the changes they made and how
much revenue uh the business is now
doing so in 2016 it was 13 2020 it was
40 20123 it's going to be like 140
million in revenue from HVAC business
that he owns and he's and he like tweets
out all these interesting bits of
content about things he's doing like for
example we're giving an additional
holiday off and here's how I think that
that's going to impact the business or
we created this thing called Hoffman
University which teaches people we had
to buy a whole building for this much
money it's been very very FAS fasinating
he and cooling companies that's going to
be the new storage business we're going
to see lots of people going on and doing
that because of this guy Chris Hoffman
really fascinating stuff yeah so mine is
really really boring so uh in every
fashion house or graphic design studio
there's a book of colors called Pantone
so you might see these they're these big
fat books and you can literally just
flip through them you look at different
colors and what they've done that's
incredibly smart is they've trademarked
colors so they have intellectual prop
property where it'll be like burgundy
Blue Sapphire orange you know whatever
and this company I found out makes over
$100 million a year of Revenue and one
of the most genius things about it is
they give you that book and they say you
need to buy a new book every year
because the colors fade right from uh
being in the sun or whatever and so
they're just constantly reselling these
books people are licensing these colors
and the entire fashion and graphic
design um world is uh standardized on
Pantone so it's it's just so boring and
wonderful well we talked about wgsn
their competitor um and how I think it's
publicly traded but they're trying to
sell it for
like I think they're trying to sell it
for like $800 million because but I I
don't think they're competitors dude
this is like the lower level this is
literally the colors it's not saying
which wn's like we're going to do
research and reports we'll tell you
which colors this is like Pantone does
that too they do like they'll do like
color forecasting and trending and all
that kind of stuff too
where do they make the money is it on
the books is it on the the dieses or is
it on the reports do you know I think
all of it and then if they use the color
so they'll say like this color of red is
going to be in next season or whatever
and if you want to use it we have some
IP around so wgsn did 50 million in iida
last year um and they've been around for
like 30 years we I I've been like
obsessed with this space for a minute I
I remember Sean you remember I used to
bring this up I think at our old office
um I've been loving this stuff uh
panton's a good one and I I think it's
wgsn and Pantone like own this space
it's basically like when Starbucks is
going to come out with their new
uniforms or their new like Christmas
sleeves or their cups they refer to each
of these companies to figure out which
colors are going to be popular in six
months uh yeah it's a really fascinating
company and they've been around for a
long ass time too love it all right
let's do next category so next category
is content of the year what are the
either books or blogs or TV shows or pod
C what was the best of the best right
we're all inundated with so much content
and we all kind of want a little bit
less content but we still want the best
so what was the best content that you
consumed this year what was yours okay
I'll give you one uh so on the TV side
the bear season two episode seven you
guys seen this this stressful but that's
a great episode I've tried to watch it
so many times side Jacks I like Breaking
Bad I love stressful shows there's
something about the way that that show
is cut where I just can't watch it I get
too stressed out and I have to turn it
off it's like uncut gems yeah I heard
about this for this show so many times I
started I I I wasn't stressed I was
actually just kind of like cool it's
kind of slow you know like I'm not like
there's not really that much going on
it's like almost so real it's like the
you know a restaurant is not that
exciting but I kept hearing about this
episode so I powered through I watched
the whole first season the whole second
season just to get this one
episode and I by the by the time I got
there I was like there's no way this is
worth it
totally worth it that is one of the best
episodes of Television I have ever seen
is such an emotional uh you know High I
love that episode I I remember where I
was sitting when I watched that and just
thinking whoever made this you are
incredible and it teaches you a ton
about business like everyone after
watching that episode went and read the
book what's it called like great
Hospitality yeah un un something
unbelievable Hospitality or something
right it's so there's a lot of business
Tak ways what was the other one Sean
I'll give you one more so I'll give you
a book that I I liked this year um it's
called have you read this it's called
talk like Churchill stand like Lincoln
no what is that uh so I go down these
random rabbit holes while I try to get
better at let's say storytelling or
public speaking or you know things like
that this is one that's on speaking and
storytelling that I I really liked
didn't expect to like it I like the
title though talk like Churchill stand
like Lincoln and it's a very simple book
and a lot of it is kind of obvious
things but I found it to be a very
useful book and it is uh it's about how
to speak better and how to carry
yourself better in different situations
Sam you love it there's a whole there's
a whole chapter on on dress how you how
you how you should dress and why you
should dress the way you dress uh
there's a whole whole chapter on that
and it's very short chapters that are on
simple principles with a ton of examples
and it's it's a very old book uh so like
I don't think a lot of people will read
this book in general um and all of the
examples are from like you know old
presidents and stuff that happened like
you know before 1950 so I think it's
just like a I don't know it's like an
old book or uses old examples but it's a
good one I recommend it uh it's not the
best book I've ever read but again I
just found it a very simple useful book
for anybody that wants to get better at
uh how they carry themselves and how
they present themselves that's a good
one um all right so there's this idea
with uh stoicism that philosophy of
stoicism I forget the exact term but
basically it's where you imagine all the
worst things have happened they say
you've got cancer your sick and dying
your parents are dead now open up your
eyes and none of that's true and you're
grateful I love that idea and so this
year I went on a spree where I read
books about people's hardship so I read
the wager which was a 10 out of 10 it's
about a shipwreck and these guys are
stranded for two years and I read like
literally four different shipwreck books
I read about Lewis and Clark and how
they spent two years going through um
America in order to find the other side
of the country and and all these
hardship because it makes my life feel
better when I'm just complaining about
like a blog post so another thing that I
really got into it's on Netflix it's
called World War II from the front lines
and there's two things that I've been
obsessed with the this year a hardship
and so seeing like these soldiers and
the Jews and what they went through
through the Holocaust and the soldiers
on D-Day it makes me so much so thankful
that I don't have to do that and I'm
like oh this shit's easy this money sh
stuff's way easy the other thing that
I'm obsessed with is charisma even evil
charismatic people so I got like I read
all these books about Charlie Manson
about hit about Lincoln about George
Washington and I love seeing this and
you see that In This World War II
documentary what they do is they take
real life footage from that era and they
colorize it and you see like uh you know
Joseph gobl one of the um one of the
folks in one of the guys who led
propaganda for Nazis you see him giving
a speech and you see all you see
literally a million people in the crowd
like being convinced to do all these
evil things and I find it so fascinating
how cult leaders like use their Charisma
to do to force people or convince people
to do bad stuff and so World War II from
the front lines it's on Netflix it's
awesome that's probably the best thing
that I've consumed this
year what's yours Andrew so um like
everyone else I've been freaking out
about Ai and I go through these phases
where I try not to think about it too
much and then I go down a rabbit hole
and I decided to read two books at the
same time that kind of counterbalance
one another so one book is called the
coming wave it's by one of the
co-founders of open Ai and it's really
fascinating usually you get these kind
of like thinkpiece analysis books by
academics or professional authors um and
this guy actually is you know he's been
on the front lines for the last 15 years
um built Deep Mind and has been at
Google uh working on you know their AI
programs for years so um and he he has a
very um extreme view that effectively AI
will disrupt all work and that the
second and third order consequences are
just endless uh and we can't really
contemplate them and he kind of argues
for regulation and containment and then
on the flip side at the same time to
counterbalance the anxiety of reading
that I've been reading Morgan housel
Morgan howel's new book same as ever
which is about how things don't change
what are the things that stay the same
over the long term you know people still
eat the same candy bars they still enjoy
reading a book they like going for a
walk in nature Etc so th those have been
two uh books that I've absolutely loved
and then I second the book The Wager
like Sam before I go to bed uh I always
read books about people in terrible
situations or in Worlds that are very
different than the world inhabit and the
wager is amazing I'm just at the part
where they're going around the horn so
I'm pretty early but oh my God it's
amazing it's hard to put down isn't it
that's one of the only books I've ever
read in one sitting wow Sean you got to
get on that shipwreck uh train uh I've
got about three more shipwreck books if
you want uh I've never bought into the
St this the stoicism uh IM the negative
visualization stuff I didn't enjoy that
I do like reading about hardship or like
kind of like people who went through
things just to give yourself perspective
uh more than it more than to make myself
feel good although that's a good side
effect but I think it's more important
to have a broader perspective than just
the little narrow stuff you see in your
day-to-day life um but doesn't that
stuff just kind of like bum you out like
you know I I feel like I get the same
effect of feeling good just by um you
know being thankful for what's going
good and imagining things going well and
I can sleep easy doing that am I uh I so
the one of the most relaxing things for
me is when I'm really really stressed I
watch a show called survivor man have
you guys ever heard of this yeah the guy
who like just is on his own for seven
days and he's got to figure it out this
poor bastard they put him in like you
know the Antarctic with no you know he
doesn't even have a hatchet or
anything himself he doesn't even have a
film crew around he's got an emergency
Beacon if he's almost dying but he films
himself surviving and you see this guy
like drinking his own urine and eating
rats and digging you know digging
shelters under the ice and all this
stuff and every time I watch that I just
think how remarkable it is that I live
in this amazing worm structure I go to
bed s mask up on his forehead his like
toes tucked into the duvet as he's
watching Survivor man reading his
printed emails asking in the glow of my
peter AA red phone
right he's like ah [__] I saw blue light
two hours before bed no
EA the rats and drinking p and you're
reading the wager and like don't these
[__] know that they'll just they just
have to eat a lemon and they won't get
scurvy what a bunch of
morons um all right wildest predictions
um what's yours dude I didn't I didn't
do any Here Andrew you gotta carry us
yeah so mine is that I think assistant
and admin jobs could go away or change
radically I think that um if you think
about a lot of the tasks that personal
assist do um I think a very well-trained
Google AI that understands your Google
Drive your calendar and your email um
will be able to do probably 80% of those
tasks maybe more and I think that's
coming in the very near term um you know
these things are just progressing at
such an exp exponential rate and so
that's something I've been thinking a
lot about and I'm I'm excited you know I
think it frees up a lot of people to do
um you know more interesting work but uh
it's going to be pretty wildly
disruptive well we got to read our
predictions from last year right that I
think that's where we got to start for
this one so Andrew your prediction for
2023 was that we would see a lot of
copies competitors to gpt3 a correct you
said Google jumps in correct AWS has
something and Azure have something Azure
did the big Microsoft did the big deal
with open AI so you were pretty spot on
Sam yours was Elon dies or gets
cancelled in a serious way and then you
said open a gets regulated
the inputs happened the inputs for Elon
Musk were there the output was not dude
he's he's getting kind of like a long
slow cancellation you know progressively
uh through and by the way that's my same
prediction for the for the next year I
think Elon will admit that buying
Twitter was a mistake although I think
he's already acknowledged he's like this
is hardship that I didn't necessarily
need but I think that like with all the
advertisers leaving I've been buying ads
on Twitter I tested it like the cost per
click are like stupid cheap I don't even
want to mention that on here because
it's cut that [__] up uh but basically I
think I think that the Twitter
experiment I think it's going to live
but not under Elon or something in a
drastic way so I'm extending my 23 into
24 okay I like that my prediction was
selfish I said this is the year that I
turned the corner and actually get
shredded up get so get ripped get in
great shape and then I also said uh I
would start a company that's uh you know
special or like maybe a legacy company
uh definitely did not do the second one
didn't but I also didn't like after that
podcast I stopped thinking about that
completely and I made actually my goal
to not start a company this year um but
I and then the getting ripped I actually
got to my fattest this year but
then before the end of the year fourth
quarter was you know the clock was
draining and I came through in the
clutch and I'm now down about uh let's
see 13 14 pounds and uh I've been eating
clean for what 45 straight days uh like
perfect perf eating exactly what I want
to be doing and uh to put that in
perspective 45 days probably doesn't
sound like much it's a month and a half
um probably the longest I went of actual
perfect eating where I'm not eating a
bunch of chips or um you know ordering a
pizza or something like that you know
one night when I'm tired or stressed by
Pro probably the last time I did a
stretch would have been like seven days
would have been like the longest I had
gone just of actual clean eating and now
I'm at 45 so going great with o zic or
without he's no zic baby I'm on that no
zic plan Daddy he uh and in the YouTube
comments you every video is commenting
either your skin or your look so it's
working people are people are loving
your uh glow up what about coolest
moment of your year I have a fun one so
um last year my Coo's moment was all
about me this year it's all about
somebody else so I have a buddy who I
went to college with my buddy Dan and
Dan um we started our first business
together straight out of college so we
were like The Three Amigos um but then
we you know that company wasn't really
working out and two of the three of us
went to Australia and had this really
cool opportunity but like there wasn't
really a spot for Dan on that boat uh
meaning like you know I got a spot and I
was able to get one other guy a spot but
it was really too much for me to like
convince this Australian billionaire why
I need two of my friends to come with me
to go do this thing that was like kind
of this unspecified project and I felt
bad about that and I felt bad about that
for like a decade and I was like damn I
really wish like even if he didn't come
that we had gotten him into a good
landing spot before we made that
decision I felt like we kind of left you
know no man left behind we kind of left
a man behind and I felt bad about that I
carried that guilt he did totally fine
by the way he went and got a job at
Facebook and he uh when he was at
Facebook he went from like the bottom to
the top the bottom was his job at
Facebook initially was to like make sure
that like no penis will show up on a
news feet he's like building like penis
detection like systems to like make sure
that you never and by the way you ever
logged into Facebook and C of penis
never he Dan did a great job and so
while he was there he went and enrolled
in the Facebook developer boot camp and
like taught himself to code and um then
he became then he went out in the
marketplace did a genius thing his job
application he's like well I could say
that I've been an engineer for two years
that's not really GNA get me that good
of a job so he's like instead he went
out he he reframed it he goes um I'm a
Facebook trained engineer I know how to
do engineering at Facebook I can make
your engineering team run like a
Facebook engineering team people loved
it he got a job as CTO of a startup that
uh went on to raised you know B round C
round D round but unfortunately the
startup fizzled out and I catch up with
Dan and I say um he's like hey man you
know unfortunately my options I thought
were going to you know make me a bunch
of money didn't really work out uh you
got any other like kind of I'm looking
for a job let me know and I said you I
met this guy Andrew Wilkinson and then I
met this guy s balky and I've been
listening to this podcast that I create
and it's all about there's a bunch of
these people that are buying businesses
I said Dan have you ever consider buying
a business he's like I didn't even know
where I would start and I was like I'm
going to help you and I was like I'll I
don't I don't know ton about it but I
know more about it than you do so you
know like let me be a blue belt and help
a white belt here and so I basically
helped Dan do this search process I had
no stake in it no investment in it
except for this is one of my best
friends from college and Dan bought a
business he bought a uh so after six to
nine months and several like close calls
but you know last minute we said no no
this is not a great business don't buy
it um he buys this business and he buys
this bag manufactur bag like bag sales
company I don't know how you describe it
they don't make the bags they they they
get them made uh but they sell them to
Big retailers so like if you go walk
into like a like a Ulta all the bags at
Ulta That's My Boy Dan's company and
this guy had been running it for you
know years he had no contracts with any
of these companies he kind of ran it off
pen and paper um and so he my my friend
Dan was able to negotiate and buy this
business at a great price and he just
texted me yesterday saying that he's
only owned this business now for like
three or four months that in the just in
the the sort of five months that'll be
this year he will out of the profit of
this business after paying all the debt
that he used to buy the business he will
make more than he made at his highest
paying job as CTO already in the first
five months and he's like dude the
lifestyle is great he's like I'm kind of
working more but it's totally different
the totally different field right like I
own my own business I come in every day
I'm excited he's like I see this path
where we're going to grow he's like I'm
the bag I'm Dan the bagman and he's like
I can I can do this and this could be
like my you know like my asset that I
build because like he's like you know
even though I'm making more than I did
at my job it's even better because you
can't ever sell your job but with this I
know if I build this business up and
it's making more profits one day I could
sell this business and cash out like a
life-changing sum for me and I feel so
good that I got to you know sit shotgun
for him while he went on this ride Kudos
San what's the name of the company can
you say I don't know but if you email me
uh I'll show you to Dan if you need bags
for your business Dan's got you mine's a
bit mine doesn't have any great story so
Andrew I saw what you put that is also
mine but I'm not going to say that one
I'll go to the next one which is
actually the most important one I had a
kid this year that was my that was the
coolest moment this year um I think
Andrew you you told me what did you say
you said you're going to feel so much
Indo uh dopamine every morning when you
look at your kid and I get it now so now
it's my turn to gatekeep people and tell
people like oh you'll understand when
you have kids you'll understand
understand it I understand a little bit
and it's been awesome so that's mine but
uh Andrew you do yours I think I said um
it's like liquid MDMA gets shot into
your brain every time you look at your
baby yeah it's awesome man it's and it's
brought me closer to my wife too I have
more you know I've already I always
respected her but now there's more like
of a of a spiritual respect it's kind of
funny um but what's yours totally um so
yeah we had our first ever live MFM in
Vancouver uh what was that February I
guess uh this year and I kind of put it
on like so I I like you know texted you
guys and I was like hey we want to do
this event let's do it in Vancouver we
rented this huge theater and I remember
getting the photo of the theater and
sending it to you and we were just like
holy [__] like how are we going to fill
this thing I was really nervous about it
and uh we I remember we were backstage
and we were like peeking out and the
entire theater was packed there was a
line down the street like it was really
really crazy and this was like this a
massive multi-level theater and see like
1200 people 1 1200 1300 people or
something and I remember Sam was like
we're backstage and he goes I don't use
Facebook but I do today because I want
everyone in high school to see that I
filled a theater I need post a photo of
of of us I just love that that was such
a great moment there I remember uh Sam
you posted this photo of Alexis ohanyan
with Serena Williams and he just looks
like a like a like a Pasty nerd with
this beautiful like beautiful Amazon and
you go the Nerds win and in that moment
I was like okay the Nerds won he didn't
like what I said that by the way he was
not a fan but it was awesome that we
sold out that theater that that was a
really exciting thing and you did the
dumbest thing ever you made people pay
but then you gave the money back if they
showed up people would have just paid
yeah I know in retrospect we should have
charged um let's go to breakout of the
Year Sean what what do you have mine's
real simple um break out of the year I
think has to be OIC I feel like OIC kind
of changed the world um it's not just
like a tech thing or a business thing
like OIC is everywhere uh and and
there's I I don't know the jury's still
out on it but there's a lot of evidence
that even if OIC has you know maybe side
effects or you got to stay on it to
maintain the gains or whatever like that
people not being obese and people not
being sort of uh controlled by their
Cravings whether it's for food or
they're even seeing maybe effects for
for alcoholism that seems just like a
really really big deal and I kind of
it's kind of the cliche idea it's like
what if what if there was the magic
weight loss pill and now there kind of
is that's mind-blowing to me that there
we did it there is a magic weight loss
pill well I was picking between Brett
Taylor and OIC and so Sean do you
remember how you first heard about OIC I
think it was June of 2022 I texted you
and I was like there's this drug called
semi glutide it's I'm in New York and
it's like kind of popular amongst like
only a small group of like weird
biohackers I'm gonna try it and I tried
it and I remember messaging you or maybe
I even said in the Pod I'm like for some
you know I've got I had drinking issues
a long time ago but I was like for some
reason I even feel like I think this
might like cure that too you call you
called it 100% not not only do you show
you you showed me a picture and I was
like wow that's incredible you go um te
you go I started this semi glutide thing
I was like dude you I've never heard of
this like you're yeah I just inject this
thing and me and I'm like bro you just
inject random [__] into you like that's
not smart but you were totally on it and
then you said the I think this is g to
cure alcoholism and I remember literally
like I didn't want to laugh in your face
but I remember laughing inside being
like dude that's just like sounds like a
crazy leap uh you know you can't just
say that [__] there's no evidence of
that I just felt it I could feel it when
I so I don't use it anymore but I tested
it for a small amount of time and this
is semaglutide that's the name of the
drug or the I don't know how you even
explain it the the root drug and then
there's OIC is the brand name but I
remember like putting that in my body
and I'm like I think this is going to
cure alcoholism because you don't crave
anything and I think what's going to
happen is in 10 years we're going to see
downsides to this drug because right now
there's like very few or at least it's
impacting only small amount of people so
I think that like there's still going to
be downsides but I think that what it's
got always said he goes it's not chat
GPT it's glp1 that's the big thing glp1
this drug class is going to be way
bigger than chat gbt and I and I agree
with them I think that's a breakout of
the Year what's yours uh Andrew yeah
that's like anti-depressants or
something um so mine mine is pretty
boring it's a company called snipped and
it's a podcast player and I don't know
if you guys have this problem but often
I'll be driving that's when I listen to
podcast most and I'll hear something
incredible like a great quote or just a
great line or something I want to follow
up on later and until recently I've
either um just forgotten it basically it
goes out uh the other side of my head or
occasionally I would pull over my car
and I'd make a note or something like
that and snip basically solves that so
what snip does is it has an AI that um
basically takes the transcript it does
um like voice recognition on the
transcript of the podcast it pulls out
all the key moments so a let's say that
you want to listen to a Jo Rogan
interview but it's 3 hours and you only
really want to talk hear them talk about
stuff that isn't MMA you can jump in or
whatever but then also when you hear
something interesting you can tap a
little button in carplay or on your
phone and it'll actually grab the text
from whatever was just said and I found
that incredibly useful and all my nerdy
friends that are into like journaling
and readwise and all that stuff are
going crazy for it so I love that
product you're on the homepage um a
testimonial from you that's cool oh
really yeah
they apparently you must I haven't
invested or anything you've tweeted it
out and they used their tweet and I
think MFM is yeah MFM is on here too um
that's pretty cool Sam you had you had a
snipped moment last pod where somebody
was like yeah vaa is this crazy company
they uh and we were like what do they
even do they go they go to yeah they're
manufacturing drugs in space Sam goes
there's a pause he goes
why he goes what like what's to
manufacture Jo in space like what's
wrong with
Massachusetts I still haven't gotten a
good answer I'm sure it exist what's
wrong with Massachusetts is just that is
incredible incredible content this is
the end of the Millie Awards
congratulations folks this is uh the end
of
2023 it's already
2024 which is crazy I saw someone say um
a professor was like hey you you can use
um sources in your paper from the
previous century and this person the
student wrote in and she goes uh Hey it
I was going to do something from the
late uh 20th century is 1996 is that too
old to use um so if you're born in 2000
you're already 24 I can't believe we're
going into that year dude that's us now
too old to use yeah it's crazy um well
that's it that's the Pod congrats
[Music]
fellas